y los paramédicos se evacuaron a varios
fieles musulmanes heridos durante los
enfrentamientos en la mezquita de
al-aqsa también conocida como el monte
del templo
estábamos sentados en al aqsa cuando
entró un gran número de policías
arrojaron botes de gas lacrimógeno en
granadas paralizantes dispararon balas
de goma e intentaron sacarnos de al aqsa
pero muchos jóvenes lograron permanecer
adentro al mediodía del lunes unas 200
personas habían sido trasladadas a
hospitales y tratamos lesiones en la
cabeza estable acciones en los ojos
muchas de ellas heridas en el estómago
man ya varios médicos también resultaron
heridos
abdomen
horas más tarde a los fieles musulmanes
se les permitió regresar a la mezquita
pero la policía mantuvo alejados a
algunos de los palestinos más jóvenes
para evitar nuevos enfrentamientos vete
a casa ahora te dije que es hora de ir a
casa
cuidado
la ira aumenta en otra parte del este de
jerusalén
los nacionalistas judíos presionan para
desalojar a varios palestinos de sus
hogares luego de que un tribunal
dictaminará que sus casas fueron
construidas en terrenos propiedad de
judíos
esto significa que mi país mi gobierno
está conmigo ahora no con los
terroristas
[Aplausos]
los nacionalistas judíos habían planeado
marchar a través de jerusalén para
celebrar la unificación de la ciudad y
de paso la anexión de los vecindarios
palestinos
la marcha que significa una provocación
para muchos fue prohibida en los barrios
musulmanes por primera vez en siete años
palestinos de gaza dispararon cohetes
hacia jerusalén